hello everyone and welcome to today's
live broadcast DNA star software for
accurate variant detection and
validation in targeted gene panel data
sets presented by Matthew Kaiser we are
excited to bring you this educational
web seminar presented by lab roots and
sponsored by DNA star DNA start
incorporated is a global software
company headquartered in Madison
Wisconsin and has been meeting the needs
of life scientists for more than 25
years the company was born out of the
e.coli lab of dr. Fred blattner
professor of genetics at the University
of Wisconsin in 1984 it's early products
reflected this background in association
and DNA star has built a strong
reputation during the Sanger sequencing
years of providing outstanding desktop
software for DNA and protein sequence
assembly and analysis to learn more
about DNA star please visit www
moderator for today's event this
presentation has been approved for
continuing education credits if you want
to obtain the credits please click on me
get your free CD credits buttons located
in the lower left of your screen this
will take you to a page listing all of
our speakers and presentations please
select the CD button under the
presentation and follow the instructions
to claim your certificate before we
begin I would like to remind everyone
this event is interactive we encourage
you to participate by submitting as many
questions as you want at any time you
want during the presentation just click
on the green Q&A button located in the
lower left of the presentation window
type your question into the box that
appears on the screen will answer as
many questions as we have time for at
the end of the presentation also please
notice that you'll be viewing this
presentation in the slide window to
enlarge the window just click on the
screen icon located on the lower right
and finally if you have trouble seeing
or hearing the presentation please click
on the support button at the top right
of the presentation window or use the
Q&A button to let us know you're having
a problem thank you now I'd like to
interview in
News Matthew Kaiser he is senior manager
of NGS applications for DNA star where
he has helped scientists address their
sequence assembly and analysis
challenges for the past seven years met
sole focus at DNA star is supporting
customers and next-gen sequencing
applications using DNA stars broad
software tool set he helps customers
with their template and de novo assembly
projects transcriptomes exomes
metagenomic assemblies are an AC chip
seek and numerous other unique
experiments matt has helped hundreds of
scientists optimize their workflows
using DNA stars next-gen software
solutions is also spoken at numerous
conferences and workshops regarding the
capabilities of DNA stars and next-gen
software tools please join me in
welcoming Matthew Kaiser I will now turn
the presentation over to him thank you
Judy and thanks for the wonderful
introduction and thanks to those that
are joining today I'd like to go through
a workflow that is new for DNA star and
its really been a focus for the company
the past two-plus years and again I
encourage you if you have any questions
at all please chat those in and or text
those in and I will try to address them
either gear in the seminar or at the end
and I understand i will be in contact
with some of you via email if there's
more in-depth questions that and you can
answer so this workflow really is a it's
it's something unique to our software
that it allows researchers to assess
accuracy in X own and target agree
sequencing experiments and it puts those
tools in your hands you can answer the
questions that are very important for
variation detection and confirming and
validating a process that you may have
set up and so the software provides
those tools so that it's easier for you
to assess various steps throughout the
process that includes assembly steps
snip calling snip filtering and then the
final result
and we've automated that so every
researcher has that capability and it's
not just a bioinformatics tool or or a
marketing claim by a company for for
accuracy so we provide data set we
provide the tools so you can confirm
your own accuracy as well as confirm DNA
stars claims on accuracy by running the
same data sets through the software so a
little background a DNA star Judy
provided a great background on our
company in the history of our company we
are located in Madison Wisconsin you've
got a nice picture here of Lake Monona
and the capital it's not going to look
like like that later today when a big
November storm hit so it will be very
choppy on this water but we are
centrally located the sales and the
development team are mostly located in
this Madison location and mayra what the
company really is to work with customers
get their feedback relay that to the
development team to try it in a really a
continual effort to improve our software
I also help customers with a variety of
projects so more in depth NGS questions
that they have they get stuck in a
certain part of their workflow that's
where the support with our software
really comes into play and will do will
do webinars will exchange data sets I do
what it takes to allow customers to you
know work through their problem so one
of the first aspects of commercial
software like DNA star is that it's
compatible with all the major NGS
platforms that of course includes
aluminum and ion torrent Pat bio data
for 54 is kind of on the way out but
that will be replaced by new
technologies things like nana poor so
we're working we're looking ahead we're
working with long we technology short
read technologies and we allow our
software to be flexible enough to
accommodate a variety of these different
sequencing platforms now of course each
one of the platforms has its own air
profiles and own optimizations in order
to assemble or align this data most
accurately and so software like ours can
recognize the different data types
and automatically set the parameters to
be optimal for the different platforms
so it's really important especially if
you if you're at a location that's
working with different types of data
that have a you know a single software
than I can handle those multiple data
forms if you're using open-source
software by comparison you have a
separate piece of software that handles
alumina short read de novo assemblies
versus you know I on torrentz DeNoble
assemblies your reference guided
algorithms would be separate from the de
novo algorithm and so a software package
like the anistar allows us to
accommodate these different platforms
fully which which really makes it easy
on the end user in addition to
supporting multiple platforms the
hardware requirements for a software
quite modest and as computers get more
powerful we can do more and more on
desktop computers and so for instance we
have a new workflow that that we won't
talk about today but it's one that we're
going to be promoting here in the next
few months for de novo assembly of
transcriptomes will it'll run on a
laptop computer with very modest
requirements and human genome assemblies
and exomes and partly sequencing is
really a modest core computer 16 gigs of
ram and we need enough space to do the
processing of the data so what we
typically recommend is a scratch disk
and this may be an internal drive on a
laptop I use my D Drive which is what I
swapped out my DVD ROM dried and put a
storage drive there and that that's
where most of the data is processes on
this hard drive and then of course
enough storage so for the input and
output files so for optimal performance
you know three drives but you can get by
a to drive as well just AC drive during
the operating system and programs and a
scratch so really we're looking at at
very cost-effective hardware now of
course there may be locations or you may
be in a location where it's difficult to
get any kind of a hardware upgrade we
have several customers whether you know
it's once every five years cycle before
you get new hardware we do have
solutions for you one of those solutions
is on using the hardware up in the
Amazon Cloud and this works particularly
well for setting up assemblies NGS
assemblies and the way it works is that
you had our sequin engine assembly
software on your land computer and you
set up the project just like you would
running locally except you you're going
to actually upload the data and it uses
a encrypted storage an HTTPS protocol
that uploads the data very rapidly to a
cloud data drive and then from that
cloud data drive there's one or more
amazon computers can be powered up than
to run the assemblies and then when
they're done there's a queue you can see
as the assembly is complete you can
download them using the same encrypted
and secure protocol so it's really a
great way to work with NGS data
especially if you're if you have a limit
on the type of hardware you have or in
some instances if you have a large
number of assemblies that you that you
want to run in a short time you can
basically spool up as many cloud
instances as you need so if I had 50
exomes that I need done you know
overnight or in half a day I can set up
50 exomes send them up to the cloud run
the assemblies and have them done in
just a few hours so now cloud is of
course just getting traction some folks
are still hesitant to use cloud but it
really is starting against momentum with
customers as they see the advantages to
having the cloud storage and the ability
to use Amazon is a nice new hardware
that's up on the cloud our software's
also comes with excellent support and so
like I mentioned earlier you know we
exchange data projects with with
customers webinars we've got over a
hundred videos demo videos on our
website and these are on all different
topics they can range from NGS projects
to protein analysis regularly molecular
biology analysis these videos are
anywhere from 30 seconds to five or six
minutes long and there
you know this wide range of topics so
it's a great resource for customers to
use to learn more about what our
software can do we also do monthly
webinars and so these webinars again are
about 50 minutes long they typically
start with a slide presentation what we
have today and then they almost always
move into the software so these are live
software demos again going back to 2012
and the archives run all different
topics there's genomics needs overviews
protein structure analysis gene panel
workflows and so forth so these are a
great resource than for for you to learn
in depth about specific workflows that
you may be interested in so one of the
first questions that we get about DNA
star software as it pertains to NGS data
is you know what is the performance a
lot of folks that you know believe that
you have had a Linux cluster to get good
performance on these very large data
sets a and this is something that we've
you know we focused on several years ago
and that was to get the optimal
performance on you know on low-cost
computers and so right now our assembly
times you know things like human genomes
which are you know for a typical alumina
data set that's over a billion reads and
this is covered about 40 x we get an
assembly time of about 13 hours and that
assembly time actually is not just the
assembly time it's the alignment of the
data it's the snip analysis and the snip
calls then it's the building of all the
output BAM files and snip files into an
output package so it's really assembly
plus all the analysis and the output
file building many software's take more
than 13 hours just to do the alignment
and then it's a whole separate step to
do all sniff analysis if you're using
open source software yet the feed
different scripts and then to produce
the snip calls that you need smaller
data sets like human exomes where you
may have a hundred million reads of
these are typically a couple of hours so
exomes RNA seek data sets you know
anywhere from one to three hours for
data sets that signs
smaller data sets like panels gene
panels or cancer panels are typically
measured in minutes in very small data
sets like bacteria just a few minutes to
do the alignments so so we have very
very fast assembly times Guinness
includes all the tertiary files that are
produced so so we've been able to do
this for some time really the focus once
we had the speed we really shifted our
focus then to improving the accuracy and
we're able to work on the speed quite
early because these NGS data sets have
been available for quite some time but
the accuracy is a different question and
the accuracy really was dependent on
having an answer that we could check our
answer against a validated answer and so
that actually kind of held up the
accuracy developments until later you
know till later in the process and one
of the critical pieces and we'll go into
this in more detail for this for this
webinar is a data set that's available
at the genome in a bottle consortium and
the genome in a bottle has a particular
human genome it's called na 12 878 that
has been sequenced by many different
sequencing technologies in sequence with
a variety of alumina lion torrent with
solid of four or five four spot sequence
of sanger data and what the result is
several million snips that have been
verified to a high degree of accuracy
and with that answer were able to use
that information is publicly available
to take that those answers run the data
through our own a winery snip collar and
then check against the answer and see
how accurate we are and so we make an
accuracy can claim on gene panels and
axons for detecting known snips in this
data set and also in some other data
sets that are that are smaller in size
at about ninety nine point seven percent
is a typical accuracy now of course the
answer isn't quite a hundred percent
it's close to 100 percents probably 99.9
and some change percent accurate and so
where we have this very small number of
miss
variations and we go and we can look at
those and figure out is it an assembly
issue is it a snip going issue that a
filtering issue or is it an air in the
answer and if it's an air and the answer
we go back to Geno in a bottle
consortium and say it if there's no air
and the answer so that's really the work
we've been focusing on you can see here
there's a link for a white paper that
describes this process in great detail
and shows you where you meet the data
sets i'm going to show you the process
of how it's set up in our software to
run these kind of validation experiments
in our own software so the validation
workflow then is part of the gene panel
workflow so gene panels of course can be
you know detecting Mendelian snips or
cancer somatic snips and a validation
workflow in a targeted resequencing is
generally a known region you know
amplicons exons sets of genes for the
focuses and the validation is also a
targeted area it is it is the region of
high confidence or snips have been
called and so this is one of the
workflows now in the DNA star software
that's accessible for our customers so
now this is kind of a kind of a busy
slide here let me see if I can get a
highlighter going here okay and so this
is kind of a flow chart to show you how
the data is fed into our software and so
if we look in the top left here the
targeted region file on the green right
here so this green tarded regions file
that's typically a bed file and the bed
file then is a list of those high
confidence of areas that you have or the
list of areas that you've targeted in
your XO more gene panel experiment now
you might have it's pretty rare but you
may have all the known snips in that
file so if it's a data set that you're
familiar with you may have a hundred of
thousand several thousand variants in
your region of interest and if you do
you'll have a known variants
VCF file right so you can take that bed
file that VCF file feed it into the sikh
man engine software through the
assembler of the variant collar and then
the variant annotator using your raw
input data your bed file your VCF file
and that can be fed into our software to
get accuracy calculations and a final
report where we get the accuracy
measurements so some customers have
access to that many customers do not
however they don't have that or the
answer that they have is you know 10
snips 20 snips which aren't enough to
really validate an entire process so to
make that validation more meaningful we
can take these bed files and intersect
them with the NIS T high confidence
regions bed file so these are the big
answer all the snips we can intersect a
bed file from genome na 12 878 that you
so you can run that sample through your
process use the genome in a bottle bed
file in a list of known variants load
that into our software with this na 12
878 data set and really validate your
process and what you're actually
validating then is you know did you did
you sequence all the targeted areas did
the assembler the DNA star assembler do
a good job the snip called you a good
job and so at each step in the process
there's a possibility for some loss of
accuracy and I've being able to
interrogate each step along this process
using our software you can troubleshoot
and improve in certain areas if you
didn't have the ability to go back and
look at the assembly to look at the
integrity each step you just get a final
answer and really no idea you know how
to improve it or where your loss of
accuracy was so this is something that
we will but i'll show you in our
software here so i didn't mention
earlier assemblies on the cloud so if
i'm going to start my project i may
choose to do an assembly in the cloud so
this is seeking an engine
seek man engine is the starting point
for most of the DNA star NGS workflows
what we're looking at here is a
screenshot of the wizard that sets up
the project so I'm a I'm create a new
assembly project and all this here or i
might start an assembly on the cloud
when i do a cloud assembly i just enter
credentials and that allows me that
access that cloud data drive and then
the amazon cloud computers so depending
on what you want to do create a new
assembly project locally and my land
machine for I can go from the cloud the
interface is virtually identical and
this is an example if I if I want to do
my XM assembly in the cloud this cloud
data drive just we can create a folder
loads all these fast cue files up to the
cloud and then we're ready to go the
next important step is to load the
reference and the bed files and so
depending on the organism that I'm
working with I can go to the DNA star
website and load in different genome
template packages and if you look I'm
going to make this little bit bigger so
I can see it better so you can see that
we've got a honey bee and a rabbit opsys
and cow a number of different model
organisms and these model organisms are
the annotated genbank chromosome
sequences bundled together with a DB
snip build so you can see the top of
this header we had BB snip build numbers
and then the assembly is the version of
the genome right so we package these up
for customers so they can download them
use them for their analysis and so in
this case we would load a human genome
assembly and once we human genome
package excuse me once we've done that
we can also load it in template files we
load in the targeted region file so
again from the wizard snapshot here's a
targeted region file it's typically a
bed file or it could be a manifest file
from from aluminum so that's the
template that we're going to align
against our genome are
add file and these these intersected
files there's kind of a schematic here
so the bed file that I use again it
might just be a vet file where I know
the snip the snips that are in that
region and I can just go with that if
you're going to use the genome in a
bottle the na 12 878 then you can
intersect it and this is something we
can help customers with and the idea is
that on human chromosome 1 we have a
number of regions that can be called
with high confidence so the NIS T bed
file are these red bars here and they
cover about ninety percent of the human
genome there are certain regions that
can't be sequencing accurately and so
the bed file then just lists all the
high confidence areas in the human
genome now your bed file for your gene
panel may be a much smaller region on
the human genome and that's what these
rectangles represent they represent my
gene panel bed file plus these little
pink diamonds which are the known snips
in that area so if i'm going to validate
my process i can intersect my own bed
file with the NIS t bed file and then i
should have a set of snips in those
regions in those coordinates that i
should detect it near a hundred percent
and that's what I'm going to use for my
answer so no matter what your capture
technique is whether you did your own
custom panel or if you got exome data
from a vendor if you sequence na 12 878
using that targeting technique you can
calibrate your process once you
intersect this kind of a bed file so
then I can load in the sequence files
and so here again is the sequent engine
wizard and I can see all the data here
that's loaded in sequin engine wizard
allows me to set up multiple samples and
I can run these as separate projects and
so when I do that I can have as many as
you know 50 exomes at a time I can load
all the data in I can set the experiment
name each experiment so I'll have in
this case it's na 12 878 but I may have
that as a control exome and they have
you know 49 additional exomes that I'm
going to run and so the wizard allows me
to set up the whole process if I run
this on my land computer I have many
exomes they'll be done consecutively so
we'll start one XOM it finishes the
second one schools up roughly two hours
correct so I run the same project in the
cloud it would be all at the same time
so I can get 50 done at the exact same
time which is a big advantage so loading
a VCF file containing these confirm
variant positions so again this is the
this is the VCF file that is a 10 is T
and this is the set of answers
essentially and this is going to be my
control and my validation control right
so I may have my NS t ni st file or I
may have my own VCF file it contains a
set of answers so when we take all these
together then everything that
contributes to variant called accuracy
we have the coverage and targeted areas
which there can be significant loss here
so for example if you're targeting
technique is not very specific if it
grabs pseudogenes if it the probes were
ineffective you may have significant
loss in that only eighty percent or
ninety percent of the reasons that you
intended to sequence were actually
captured so that's one point where there
can be lost it's the and that's again
it's the coverage and it's a specificity
so specificity then is the probes or
primers may actually grab similar genes
or pseudogene so you get thinner
coverage in those areas so our software
provides a mechanism then to analyze
what the coverage looks like and what
the capture efficiency was then we have
the mapping efficiency and mapping
efficiency really is the DNA star
algorithm how good is the actual mapping
and alignment algorithm that's being
used and there are a number
different alignment algorithms there's
the sikh man engine there's open-source
algorithms like bwa is probably 50
different algorithms that can do some
sort of mapping in this capacity there's
lots and lots of choices here however
DNA star is the only option that allows
you to actually validate in a process to
see how accurate the actual process is
another spot for loss is the variant
filtering and this is actually a very
important part and that's how do I
separate the noise from the actual
signal that's you know in my sample and
so the type of filters that are set are
actually very very important they're set
properly for the type of data that you
have if you filter too aggressively to
remove false positives you may lose too
many true positives if you don't filter
enough if your filters are two lakhs by
default you may have a large number of
false positives um why only gaining a
few the true positives so there's really
a lot of different moving parts in these
validation workflows and again you want
to be able to evaluate each step and
then all of them together contribute to
the overall variant call accuracy so
each step there's some loss and each
step with nice improvements so the in
terms of the coverage of the targeted
areas there is reports in our sequence
software so when the assembly is done
it's possible to go and look at the
assembled data in DNA star software and
this report here i'm just going to
circle it it's called the coverage of
the targeted region so this comes right
from a bed file and what it is is it
it's an interactive report that tells me
the location and all kind of circle
these are another font is small so
that's the actual genomic coordinates
this first column is the contact ID you
can see here's NC 0 0 0 0 1 which is
human chromosome 1 it tells me the
feature gene that's their location the
length the coverage depth across that
targeted area and then the percent that
was covered and this particular fill
tables filters that you see most of them
are one
under person covered but there is one
that's at sixty three point six five
percent so what that means is that in
the bed file there was a for this
particular location there is only
sequence cover got a little more than
one half of that targeted area so that
if it's an important gene for your
analysis you may want to use this report
to go and improve the primers or probe
for that particular exon so it's one of
the first places that you look for an
exome or a gene panel to really see that
you get all the regions that you
intended to to capture and again it's
interactive so when I go to one of these
locations and if I double click on it
these other views come up so you can see
down the bottom is a strategy of you
which is like a genome browser view that
shows me a histogram for depth of
coverage and also for pair consistency
and a list of features you can see these
red Peaks are peaks of coverage and the
features little green arrows represent
the exons or segments in a CBS feature
so it's a nice way to kind of look at it
and say well you know you can see how
many exons have coverage over them
there's also a sequence view so in the
over here on the right this is actual a
line data them and so you can go and
look at the aligned data that's very
important for specific sniffs you know
if you have a snip that was missed
oftentimes you can go to that location
and look at the alignment in some cases
you'll see well the snip call was one
based upstream or downstream and maybe
some gapping event occurred that caused
a snip to be off by one base pair so
it's important if you have important
snips to validate to go and look at the
assembled beta and make a judgment Carl
I don't want to do that for thousands of
snips but for particular snips that you
missed it's important to be able to do
that so that the overall specificity
then of the targeting experiment is
summarized as well in a targeted report
and a targeting report then lists a
number of different things if you look
in the bottom right here total length of
targeted reference that's the width in
that bed file in
case there was 27 mega bases of genome
that was targeted and we get the total
number of aligned reads the total number
of a line reads that are in the targeted
area and then we get an enrichment from
that and then some additional
information how much of the target was
covered at 10x how much at 20 x how much
at 50 X you can see that between 10x at
ninety three point two nine percent of
the targeted areas code is covered
that's typical for an exome capture that
50x only a little over eighty percent is
covered and so that gives you some idea
of where you might have filtering so if
I'm going to do a minimum coverage
filter for my snip calling I probably
don't want to go as high as 50 x I'm
probably going to lose a lot of snip
calls if I make that filter too
stringent this main window here this
coverage of targeted region i also have
a hard for you to see but it's the not
targeted regions shown here and what
that means is do i get sequence data
that's a lining outside the areas that
I've targeted and that can be a concern
if the capture technique is not specific
enough if your sequencing a lot of data
that's not going aligning to the
intended areas you're going to want to
know what the reason is and you can see
here something that really jumps out is
pseudo so in this particular experiment
many different pseudogenes were captured
and if I look at the number of reads you
know the depth is 19,000 X coverage so
it's a massive pileup of reads for some
of these pseudogenes so in some cases
you would go back and maybe redesign and
make again probes or primers more
specific so if these sealer genes aren't
Patrick some cases you can't avoid it
the pseudo jeans are just too similar if
there are other strategies to avoid that
so once the data has been aligned to the
targeted areas and the algorithms then
can go through and identify how many of
those of those positions have been
detected there's several different
metrics that are calculated
and that includes true positives and
false positives and true negatives and
false negatives and from that those raw
bits of information can calculate false
discovery rate sensitivity and
specificity and as I mentioned earlier
there's oftentimes a trade-off there is
a trade-off between true positives and
false positives for instance in many
cases if I don't apply any filtering at
all just let everything come through I
may get slightly more all the true
positives that are in that sample but I
may increase the false positives by
thousands of percent percentage points
so I made you know by your moving all
the filtering I'm essentially letting
all the sequencing noise come through
into the variant analysis so in most
cases that's not desirable so you have
to apply some filtering and that really
becomes the challenge is how to find the
optimal balance here and then another
the false negatives of course for
anybody doing clinical work in
particular that's one of the biggest
concerns is you don't want to have a
false negative and Miss true variations
that are present in the sample so really
false negatives become you know a really
big deal and so you want to be able to
run your data through and figure out
what your false negative detection rate
is and what your balance is between true
positives and false positives and again
things like sensitivity which is the
true true positives divided by the true
positives plus false negatives so you
get a couple of metrics here and with
very detection there isn't any one
single metric that is baci you kinda
have to look at several of them to come
up with a conclusion as to you know what
the best answer is so some of the
results then when we run and know what
this is is human genome na 12 878 and
it's through an exome so these are these
exomes are you know in these regions
there's about fifteen to sixteen
thousand true positive corals and so
this is one of our results tables and
it's where we compare our seat men
engine software to four different
competitors that use similar kind of
kind of work and really the kind of a
industry standard is the BW a map or
which is often use aluminum with the
gatk snip caller so these first two are
open source Linux command line softwares
two different versions of their Smith of
the gatk snip parlor then we have to
commercial competitors CLC bio ingenious
and these are again are all running the
same same data set and we're checking
against the answer that's at genome the
bottle consortium and so when we look at
some of the metrics sensitivity DNA you
know they're all above ninety percent of
DNA star and bwa gtk are both above 99
percent in this case we're for this data
set we're at about ninety nine point
five six so what a half percent better
than bwa the false positive discovery
rate on you can see bwa gatk is actually
slightly lower a little bit lower than
sea pen engine the commercial
competitors very high well about seven
percent and so when we look at true
positives you know they're all at 15,000
range false positives again seek man
engine and BW agt care are the lowest
and the other two commercial competitors
are extremely high over 1200 false
positives false negatives this look
second the last column a sequin engine
is the lowest by quite a wide margin so
67 false negatives and you can see gatk
has about twice as many and then many
more for genius and CLC so when you take
all that information combined you can
see that Sigmund engine and bwa gtk are
the two best performers with a slight
edge I would say to Sigmund engine due
to the much lower false negative
detection rate you can also factor in
the amount of time that it takes to
process these data sets seek been engine
again is about an hour and a half pwa at
six hours and roughly 30 the commercial
competitors so we take it all together
you really strongly believe that the
secret engine is
best performer in terms of accuracy and
and with speed so what another question
I can come up as well that you know did
we just cherry-pick a data set where we
perform the best there are actually
three X own data sets different na 12
878 exomes propria prepared through
different capture techniques and these
are public data sets one from the
daughter bond Institute one from Arab
labs and one from Mount Sinai and so
these are yen exome captures from the
same referencing genome and you can kind
of see you know very similar results the
Garvin and air flabs it's your pot it's
about 15,000 true positives the Mount
Sinai data set is much larger there's
35,000 through positives here so it's a
really big data set it is ideal for
calibrating software and to be used as a
measurement for accuracy you can see
what this Mount Sinai is actually the
best what we published in our marketing
materials was the garmin institute exo-m
it's the one that we first had access to
you but really the Mount Sinai gives the
best result 27 false negatives 99.9 two
percent sensitivity takes a little
longer to assemble to fill out figures
but we get just fantastic results really
with all the exomes but it's very
consistent there are additional data
sets that are being produced by genome
in a bottle for additional human genomes
I fink there's me a cancer data set as
well as those datasets become available
we will do additional white papers and
different measurements of accuracy and
make sure that our customers have access
to those datasets so they can do their
own their own measurements so one final
mention here on something thats related
to the workflow is a little a new piece
of software that will be coming out
early in 2016 that is related to this
validation workflow and we call it the
human variant annotation database and so
for these workflows there's additional
information
that you may want to pull into your
project and that information may include
things like a genome allele frequencies
and clen bar scores and thousand genomes
information and functional predictions
like sift and polyphen indication taster
and so these database information is
available at DB NSF p we can import that
into our software that in rich's the
event variant analysis so it's a new
piece of information that we can pull in
and software that's something related
this work for it will see early in 2016
now and with that I'd be happy to take
any questions I see there might be one
here that so I do have a question from
jing wang and the question is are your
software doing two main things assembly
the data assembling the data identifying
the variation within genes yeah that's
it that's exactly what what our software
is doing so in addition to this the
validation process our software does the
Assembly of the fast queue data it gives
visualization so that we can look at the
assembled data and it will identify all
the variations in that data it can be
used to analyze single samples or we can
scale up and you know compare the
variance across you know 50 exomes or or
multiple genomes worth of data so we can
really scale up to very very large
projects so again thank you and I'll
stick around here there's any additional
questions I'll be more than happy to to
answer them
thank you Matt for that informative
presentation indeed it is time for QA if
you a question you'd like to ask Matt
please do so now one person already did
so just click on the green Q&A button at
the lower left of the presentation
window type your question into the box
that appears on the screen and click on
the send button and we will answer as
many of your questions as we have time
corn I'll give you a moment to formulate
questions
okay if there are no more questions I
would like to once again thank Matthew
Kaiser for his presentation do you have
any final comments Matt um thanks Judy
again uh you know thanks for attending
today thank you again Matt looks like we
had a little technical problem there for
a moment but but thank you again for
your presentation and for your response
there I would also like to thank our
sponsor DNA star for making today's
educational webcast possible a reminder
this presentation has been approved for
continuing educational credits if you
want to obtain my credits please click
on me get your free CD credits button
located in a lower left of your screen
this will take you to a page listing all
of our speakers and presentations please
select the CD button under the
presentation and follow the instructions
to claim your certificate before we go I
want to everyone know that today's
webcast will be available for on-demand
viewing through May eleventh 2016 you'll
receive an email from lab roots letting
you know when this webcast will be
available for replay we sure that
announcement with your colleagues who
may have missed today's live event
that's all for now thank you for joining
us we hope to see you again soon goodbye